[Music]
I'm dyeing my hair pink tonight me and
my sister are doing it we're just gonna
lather it on because my hair so white I
got these thick ass extensions in when I
like let my hair out it's like bacon
like poofy so it'll be like Oh like pink
like really ultra different pink vibes
and poofy and then after I'm done with
these guys I'm just gonna take him out
and I'm gonna have like my regular hair
which is like down to here and just do
pink until I go back into red Bella
Thorne DZ and her new hot pink do to et
just last week the 19 year old rocked
the fiery look at EDC over the weekend
in Las Vegas where she opted for a
fierce fairy look what's kind of
inspiring your choices lately I love
changing up I like to do it all while I
have a minute
so because I'm allowed right now and
nobody's like you can't do it like god I
do like three different hair colors
three months but for my style it really
just depends on like the group crew that
like I'm going out with sometimes I go
super dark and you're like woah so dark
today I got like these huge creeper moon
boots on I'm just like fishnet so I'm
like looking super dark and then other
times it just like this which is more on
like the rare occasion and then I just
yeah I just have very different styles
but like in each thing that I wear even
if it's like more cleaned up looking and
like ooh classy today I still have like
my weird little quirks like with like my
mismatching socks yeah so it's still
always like
you